سيعود مع العديد من الدبلوماسيين الى
فرنسا في الساعات القادمه وسننهي تعاوننا
العسكري مع سلطات الامر الواقع في النيجر
[موسيقى]
اخبروا العالم بانجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم ماكرون يعلنوا انهاء
الوجود الدبلوماسي والعسكري الفرنسي في
النيجر بعد شهرين على الانقلاب وبذلك تصل
قضيه طرد السفير الفرنسيه من اليمين الى
خواتيمها قالت الانقلاب رحبوا بالخطوه
ودعوا الى مواصله ما وصفوه بالنضال لتحقيق
طموحات المستقبل
مئات المتشددين اليهود يقتحمون بحات
المسجد الاقصى فيما يعرف بيوم الغفران تحت
حمايه قوه الاحتلال ووسط تضييق تجاري على
الفلسطينيين دائره الاوقاف الاسلاميه
ادانت الاقتحام واعتبرت الخطوه تكريسا
لخطه التقسيم الزمني والمكني للمسجد
الاقصى حضور دبلوماسي لافت في العاصمه
الارمنيه حيث بحث وفد من الخارجيه
الامريكيه ووزير الداخليه الروسي مع
المسؤولين التطورات في كندا وذلك مع
استمرار نزوح الالاف من الاقليم نحو
ارمينيا من جهه اردوغان لاغتنام فرصه
الاستقرار
نقابه الكتاب الامريكيه واستديوهاتو هوليو
تتوصلن الى اتفاق مبدئي من شانها ان ينهي
اضرابا استمر قرابه خمسه اشهر ويعد الاطول
منذ عقود حيث اوقف معظم انتاج الافلام
والتلفزيون وكلف الاقتصاد الامريكي حوالي
خمسه مليارات دولار وفقا لتقديرات
الاقتصاديين الى اللقاء